hey guys it's justine and today we're
doing a video that i've been wanting to
do for a really long time but i haven't
really been traveling much
and i'm about to head out on a really
fun road trip and i'm going to show you
guys
everything that i'm bringing with me to
make content and
it's a lot of stuff and this is actually
kind of pared down i took out some
things i was like i'm only bringing the
things
that i think i'm gonna need and then the
things that i think i might actually
need that i thought that i wouldn't need
but i might need it
so we're gonna just put it in here so
just in case i didn't bring the things
that i thought that i might
not really know we get the point so huge
thank you to owc for sponsoring this
video
and this is actually a perfect video to
integrate this in because this is their
usbc travel dock not only does this have
pass through charging but it also has
two usb 3.1 ports a usb seat and
thunderbolt 3
hdmi outs and an sd card slot one of the
things that i really like
is you are able to fold the cable up and
it's already connected so you don't have
to worry about
never having a cable to plug it in since
they launched this thing i pretty much
have used it non-stop so if you guys
want to check it out i'll put a link in
the description
owc has so much cool stuff i am working
on a full tour of all of the owc stuff
that i've been using so stay tuned for
that and this
this precious piece is actually going
into
the top laptop bag because it needs to
be accessible
and handy whenever i need it so i broke
my packing down into
basically three sections so i have all
of the podcast gear
in this container i have kind of my
laptop bag which has like my ipad
my computer and all kinds of accessories
that i might need quickly or while we're
on a road trip and then over here i've
got this massive pelican case i end up
getting three different size pelican
cases
one for larger tripods and then a
smaller little air one for smaller road
trips but this is gonna be a very long
road trip so i needed to bring
the big boy for this one so let me show
you how i have this laid out
now normally you're supposed to mount
this kind of
up here but i pack this part so full
that if i put this like this it won't
close
so i have to go like this and i just
cover that all up and then this little
dome kind of covers up all this stuff
and then when i get to my destination i
just open it back up this
up there i'm actually gonna put some
velcro here i need to make a note to
remind myself to do that and
i have easy access to anything that i
need you will notice that there is a
little space here and that's because
uh i've got a secret thing that's going
here so
i couldn't put it in here but normally
this is
filled to the brim with something just
trust me there's something there but
what i do have here right now in the
meantime
is actually going to go in here this is
also an owc drive i just recently got
this this is their envoy pro ex
this is a thunderbolt three drive this
is a four terabyte solid state drive
i've been editing all of my videos off
this
tyler's been editing all of our videos
off of this the two terabyte drives just
weren't cutting it anymore for me
so to be oh look at that look at you
look at you anyway the speeds on this
thing are incredible
and now that we're shooting in 8k
sometimes this was one of the first
drives that i bought
and it basically had changed my editing
life now this is a newer version
this is actually a 16 terabyte
thunderblade drive
i had bought the 8 terabyte solid state
drive whenever
actually when i was shooting that 8k mac
pro video because i ran out of space
everywhere
so it was the only drive that i could
find that would be able to handle all
the footage and now they have a 16
terabyte one so they did send me this to
check out
i mean if you're somebody that goes
through a lot of storage and you need to
be able to edit off of it directly this
is a solid state raid so there are
drives inside of this and it's
life-changing
i love you see it back i also love this
little pneumatic bag
this thing i'm always putting random
stuff in here random stuff whatever i
want oh this is something that's also
fairly new so this is the blink pro
by saramonic and i had used the previous
version of these and these new ones have
this little charging
container so you can just see those
little charging conductors there i've
actually been using this with the sony
zv1 because that does have an audio
input
so with this receiver i have these two
transmitters
that i can give one to me or to my
sister and both of our audio
will go onto the same track so normally
these two cameras that we're actually
using right now
would be in here so over here i have one
just to show you the placement this next
little section
is kind of just everything that is sort
of like this shape microphones
tripods mobile mounts
it's clean lenses we've got the dji osmo
for our xlr audio
we've also got this little rig which
we've been using for the new
sony a1 some little nan lights two of
those
360 stick and there's also
power strip fits very nicely just like
so now over here is also going to be a
secret little
section of something that i can't show
you yet but what i can show you are
these incredible
cases that aldrin made for the mavic
mini these are so cool and they fit
perfectly in here
so i love this because i can fill these
up with whatever i want if i'm not using
it for my mavic mini and the controller
and they fit perfectly in here i was so
excited in this little section we've got
my drone the mavic air 2 very nicely
placed
and again like i was telling you guys
these trek packs are so cool
because i just kind of put my item in
and cut these pieces to fit
and they're pretty standard sizes too so
i'm able to kind of reconfigure it later
okay tyler i've got a question so over
here
we've got a lot of nd filters and stuff
like which ones
do i should i keep we've got some peter
mckinnon we've got some moment ones
what do you think i mean they don't take
them that much
are you saying i bring them all you
bring them all okay let's bring it all
so much for paring things down oh we've
also got our
sd card packet full of
actually not sd cards these are the cf
express cards they don't fit in here
and back here is where i've put all the
lenses and i've got these little peter
mckinnon
back cap stickers so the lenses that i'm
going to be bringing with me i've got
the
24 millimeter this is the 1.4 this is
so beautiful boy this is our 135g master
we've got our 12 to 24. this is a 2.8
and we've got our 85 millimeter that's a
1-4 we're also going to be bringing
the 24 to 70. is that 24-70
and then me 16 to 35 remember when i
said i was bringing only what i needed
i'm bringing only what i needed
in this little section i brought the
elgato wave 3 microphone i just wanted
to make sure i had something that was a
simple usb mic
in case i needed to record some vo and
i've also got the insta 360
up here is easy access to cables
basically any cable that i might ever
need
in here a bunch of random stuff
everybody screenshot this and tweet it
to gavin free
right now i've got an extra sim card
some tape
command strips you won't really never
know when you might need that
this is where i have all the audio we've
got extra microphones we've got our
lav pack so i use the sennheiser avx
they seem to be working quite well for
us i'm using it right now how's it sound
here's a little baggie of some
accessories i really love
little baggies and this is where
all the batteries are gonna go and so
far we only have one
none of them are charged and that's it
for the pelican case the backpack
this i'd like to keep very accessible to
anything that i might need in the car
because if i'm not driving which i'm
usually not because i'm a terrible
driver and jenna doesn't trust me
so i'm you know usually editing in the
back seat front seat doesn't matter in
this little front pocket
i always keep my air pods or whatever
headphones i have and i like keeping
this here because i can just go
look at that also in here oh it's a
secret tutorial for cubing
this is my easy access area here so i
have my owc
travel dock and also my sony zv1
air pods glasses chapstick
contacts tampons i'm a lady
love these little in case bags this is
some miscellaneous accessories the two
phones that are going to be coming with
me
other than my iphone i've got some
cables in here
you know just like a nice little mix of
just stuff i might need i love this
little bag this one's actually by away
this came with one of their suitcases
and in here i keep things that are kind
of flat
so i have my cf express oh my gosh we
have an extra card
that's good to know and then i have a
couple different cables i've also got
the
duo charger which is obviously
been game changing for traveling like
this thing is so cool
so i usually have at least one or two
mophie chargers this is a smaller one i
also have a larger version of this that
has an ac
port so i can charge things with a
normal plug although the car that we're
taking
does have plenty of outlets so we will
be able to have power
nintendo switch of course
can't leave home without it we have
the new 13-inch m1 macbook pro i love
this computer i just wish that it had
two reports
when they release the next version of
whatever mac
comes next it's gonna be mind-blowing my
ipad
air so i've mostly been using my ipad
air to do apple fitness
especially when i'm traveling because
everything is here i've got all my
workouts connects to the apple watch and
then i can also use this to do emails
or whatever else i want maybe like
watching
netflix next up this is a new addition
to the fam
my last trip i actually was able to put
all of this stuff in here
but i only brought three microphones and
this time i wanted to bring
all of the microphones this is the whole
podcast
set up minus microphone stands which
if you're going to be on my podcast and
i'm traveling you're going to hold the
microphone and i'm so sorry about it
actually no i'm not because
the microphone stands it's just an added
hassle so here it is it's all nicely
packed
got all four microphones in here we've
got the road caster pro
we've even got two sets of headphones
because jenna and i both have our own
so that would be for our potential
guests i also just recently got this
off of uh i saw it on b h it's a way to
use the road caster with a usb
tyler all the xlr cables are down at the
bottom
everything is fit in here real nice
real snug there's something oh yes
oh yes a tiny bag
adapters here for the headphones and the
cables for the headphones as well
so that my friends is
the tugo podcast obviously this is not
set up for flight so if we were going on
a plane
i would have to reconfigure this back
into the pelican case
as far as lighting goes we're gonna be
bringing the new aputure amaran
200d light it's a lot smaller and it's
really light so we're able to bring that
and probably actually we could probably
bring a smaller light stand too
since it's lighter right no
we are going to bring a bigger um
we're going to bring a c-stand so i
think that is pretty much everything
other than i make sure i always carry a
knife with me just
in case i need to cut something or unbox
something on the go
other than that
i think it's time to go i'll put links
in the description if you want to check
out anything that i talked about here
today
if there's anything that you think that
is missing from my kit don't tell me
because
i don't want to have to buy it well
thank you guys so much for watching
i'm looking forward to heading out on
this trip i'm gonna be making some
content and hopefully getting some time
to rest but that's
probably not gonna happen anytime i try
to go on a trip and say i'm not gonna
film anything i'm just gonna enjoy
there's all kinds of cool stuff to film
and make videos about so can't wait
i'll see you guys very soon bye